les affaires michel rocard contre
attaque ce soir exclusif à deux un
portage dans l'île d'anguilla lieu de
transit de 88 mille actions triangle
pechiney les profs dans la rue grèves
des manifestations
situation tendue entre les enseignants
et le ministre lionel jospin en avant
première pour les municipales lyon ce
soir
portrait politique mais aussi portraits
économique l'afghanistan les diplomates
s'en vont la france par exemple a décidé
de fermer son ambassade à kaboul
trop risqué au tableau d'honneur de la
semaine
un mannequin d'alma elle a été la
vedette des collections de printemps à
paris bonsoir deux criminels de guerre
nazis remise en liberté les pays bas ont
voulu faire un geste d'humanité ces deux
hommes qu'on appelait les deux bréda ces
deux hommes étaient depuis 43 ans dans
des prisons en hollande notamment il
avait été condamné à mort puis gracié
cette fois le parlement néerlandais a
décidé de les expulser vers l'allemagne
où vivent leurs familles isabelle
bechler il aura fallu quarante trois ans
et deux votes du parlement néerlandais
pour que la porte de la prison de breda
s'ouvre pour les deux criminels de
guerre nazis fisher et fument tonnes une
ambulance aux vitres calfeutrait de
papier kraft les emmène vers l'allemagne
frank fischer 87 ans et ferdinand
huffington 80 ans avait été condamné à
mort en 1950 il appartenait pendant la
guerre à ce qui s'appelait alors la
direction de l'émigration juive qui a
mené à la mort 144000 des cent cinquante
mille juifs néerlandais leur sentence
n'a pas été exécutée en 1951 leur peine
de mort a été commuée en détention à
perpétuité
habré dans la communauté juive l'opinion
hollandaise et internationales se sont
émus en 1972 à nouveau lors d'un premier
vote du parlement qui souhaitaient les
gracier comme 106 autres criminels nazis
détenus en hollande
elle avait été déjà aujourd'hui le
parlement hollandais a finalement à 85
voix contre 55 et 10 abstentions décidé
que les deux criminels de guerre devait
quitter leur univers de bréda pour
rentrer dans leur pays d'origine
l'allemagne où huit de leurs congénères
sont encore détenus et condamnés à
perpétuité et voici l'arrivée des deux
hommes en rfa ce soir rfa dont le
président richard von weizsacker a
exprimé au parlement hollandais ses
remerciements je cite pour ce geste
d'humanité jusque dans l'accomplissement
de la justice michel rocard contre
attaques à propos des affaires ce
vendredi le premier ministre était en
province à la roche sur yon
le sujet est évoqué michel rocard n'a
pas hésité à se montrer offensif
écoutez un ministres de mon gouvernement
aurait-il été tuées au coin d'une rue de
paris un autre serait t'il bord après
avoir été mis en cause dans des
opérations immobilières
d'autres encore aurait-il reçu des
diamants d'un chef d'état étranger
ou un autre membre de mon gouvernement
aurait-il fait délivrer de vrais faux
passeports
ah non bien sûr
non non bien sûr ça on l'a déjà rétorqué
on va commencer ce ne sont pas des
membres du gouvernement qui sont en
cause c'est leur entourage
s'il ya à faire c'est qu'il ya enquête
s'il ya enquête c'est pour déterminer si
la justice doit tout non être saisie
nous savons maintenant qu'elle le sera
non les affaires ne doivent pas
affaiblir la démocratie dès lors que la
démocratie c'est d'aller jusqu'au bout
de ces principes sans faiblesse sans
complaisance mais aussi sans amalgame
voilà pour l'aspect politique du côté du
feuilleton sur ces affaires l'élément
nouveau c'est le reportage que nous vous
proposons ce soir la sphère pechiney a
révélé que la fraude boursière à
laquelle elle avait donné lieu veut nez
de différentes filières filière
française filière américaine filière
proche-orientale aussi avec pour cette
dernière une escale privilégiée cela
s'appelle anguila c'est une île des
caraïbes qui est aussi un paradis fiscal
évidemment 88 mille actions triangle
pechiney auraient transité par une
mystérieuse société idb 6 à anguilla
l'équipe d'antenne 2 nicolas jacobs
c'est jean-marie lequertier s'y est
rendu une villa plutôt quelconque à
moitié cachée par la végétation dans une
île perdue des caraïbes
c'est ici le siège de l'international
discount bank
c'est d'ici que par l'entremise de la
société suisse au co finance ont été
achetés 88 l'action triangle le bureau
est vide
le patron georges samia se cache quelque
part dans l'île mais nous avons pu
rencontrer sa femme filmée à son insu
elle nous confirme que depuis décembre
hadibi collabore avec les autorités
boursières américaines et françaises
mais elle va plus loin
le dossier a été transmis
elle sait qu'avec le nom du client
et allah comme aussi
en revanche la dame samia dément tout
lien entre idb souk aux finances mais
dans l'extrait du registre du commerce
de lille il apparaît qu'à diby a changé
de propriétaire depuis un an
à l'époque parmi les actionnaires
figuraient emile haddad dont le frère
est un des directeur et actionnaire de
soko finances est ce que le nom qui
figure sur le document est le vrai nom
du propriétaire
ces noms qui figurent sur les registres
sont ceux des propriétaires
mais il va de soi qu'on ne peut jamais
être sûr si c'est non en cache d'autres
ou pas le secret c'est en fait tout le
charme de cette petite île et de sa
capitale de valve et quelques maisons en
bois que surplomb parfois une antenne
satellite en contact direct avec wall
street à peine 6000 habitants mais plus
de 300 sociétés étrangères financière
pour la plupart et qui s'épanouissent à
l'ombre d'un système fiscal paradisiaque
dans ce centre commercial un peu
particulier on retrouve la plupart
d'entre elles parfois signalés par une
plaque le plus souvent parfaitement
anonyme pour mille dollars
la seule taxe qu'il faudra payer
n'importe qui peut s'installer dans un
de ces petits bureaux une secrétaire
éventuellement à prête-noms et le
business peut commencer
et l'on fait toutes sortes d'affaires de
préférence celles qui ne doivent pas
laisser de traces ainsi le nom d'haïti
be a été prononcé lors de l'irangate ou
encore lors de la libération des otages
français
mais en guina toutes les pistes se
brouillent nombre d' enquête ne
s'échouent est au bord de ses plages que
l'on dit les plus belles des caraïbes
illustration de cette affaire en bourse
elles ne sont en fait qu'un épiphénomène
d'une activité de plus en plus forte sur
toutes les places boursières depuis le
krach de l'année dernière les bourses
ont rattrapé tous leur retard et ça
continue deux exemples paris en un seul
mois
le mois boursier de janvier paris a
augmenté de 10%
wall street ce soir autre exemple c'est
très récent
jean lambert vienne me le communiqué
très forte hausse encore à wall street
ce soir autres éclairages apportés par
la sphère pechiney le travail des
acteurs de
bourse ce sont des gens qui analyse qui
s'informent qui doivent aussi avoir du
flair
mais bien sûr qu'ils ne doivent pas
tomber dans ce qu'on appelle le fameux
délit d'initié les principaux acteurs ce
sont les agents de change
alors comment travaille-t-il claire
chazal georges en feng reportage ils
font la journée continue pour ces jeunes
de chétifs y est l'une des premières
sociétés de bourse française les marchés
ne s'arrête jamais ici ils achètent et
vendent au mieux obligations et actions
pour le compte d'une centaine de très
gros clients des banques ou des
assurances huit heures de suite au
téléphone il très facilement un milliard
de francs de transactions par jour
une sorte de choc ont chassé le prix ou
sa set signant et en même temps j'ai le
plaisir de traiter peut-être un pdf ce
qui fait qu'on aime le job mais tu fier
sert aussi d'intermédiaire pour près de
4000 clients particuliers moyennant bien
sûr une commission d prenait un peu sur
les états unis
c'est ici qu'on conseille qu'on oriente
le petit actionnaire comme le
professionnel des valeurs mobilières est
ce que on peut encore gagner de l'argent
en bourse
il y assure que deezer 88 la lys globale
c'est-à-dire la valeur moyenne de
l'ensemble des sociétés qui sont votées
en bourse a monté de 5 ans porte est-ce
qu'on peut encore faire des coupes de
beaucoup c'est tout l'art de la haye
financier du coursier de déceler quelles
sont celles ci sont sous côtés et qui
sont sous côtés ou en prêt si vous
voulez acheter c'est dire qu'ils ont
devant elles souhaitent un bel avenir
que le marché n'a pas encore décelé soie
sont brodés des résultats qu'on connaît
pas encore mais là il faut faire très
attention aux délits d'initiés dont les
pommes sur lesquels je peux pas nous
faire de décence pour moi et pour
informer les épargnants
les analystes financiers sont de le
marché épluche les notes de conjoncture
et multiplie les graphiques
ici c'est la devise
on initie pas on conseille la grogne des
enseignants étaient visibles aujourd'hui
puisque les profs étaient dans la rue
alors comme toujours il est bien
difficile de savoir l'exacte proportion
de grévistes grèves et manifestations
suivies pour les syndicats qui annoncent
par exemple 20000 manifestants grèves et
manifestations réduite pour le ministère
et la préfecture de police qui n'a vu
que 1500 manifestants à partie les
chiffres très variable qui varient aussi
si l'on tient compte par exemple ou non
des lycées professionnels
alors voyons un exemple concret ce sera
plus simple c'est registre est allé voir
comment la grève était suivi dans un
lycée de la banlieue parisienne
le lycée louise michel à champigny non
non vous ne vous trompez pas nous sommes
bien dans un lycée mais quand les profs
ne sont pas là précisément ils sont en
assemblée générale je ne connais déjà
bien méritant des professionnels
travailler avec la paye que les
conditions dans lesquelles on travaille
une phrase qui symbolise bien le climat
qui régnait à cette assemblée générale
des professeurs du lycée de champigny
ici sur 100 enseignants 60 % étaient en
grève pour des raisons bien précises
comment est-ce qu'on va recruter des
gens avec ce qu'on a actuellement comme
conditions de travail demander aux
élèves
est ce qu'ils ont envie d'être d'être
professeur à toutes ces interrogations
répondent celles des élèves conscients
du ras-le-bol des grévistes
ils ont des raisons pour la faire je
pense puisque serait vote contre je sois
il était temps qu'ils mettent en grèce à
ccc dans un petit moment qu'ils sont pas
d'accord
ailleurs d'autres professeurs assurent
leurs cours et des élèves travaillent
parmi les non grévistes il y a ceux qui
sont favorables au projet jospin il ya
ceux aussi qui ne peuvent pas se
permettre de perdre une journée de
salaire et d'autres qui ne croient pas à
cette grève
je pense que malheureusement depuis un
certain temps 24 heures de grève elles
n'ont jamais avancé c'est avancer quoi
que ce soit il faudra un mouvement
beaucoup plus dures enfants sont allés
en classe à ce matin personnellement
j'aurais demandé de ne pas aller à
l'école ce matin pour pour soutenir le
mouvement va se poursuivre par
différentes actions ainsi que des
manifestations et grève les 6 et 17
février prochain et michel rocard tout à
l'heure a lancé un avertissement aux
enseignants s'étaient à la roche sur yon
toujours fait attention au prix que vous
paierez vos hurlements at il dit si vous
vous rendez désagréable à la france
toute entière et monsieur rocard a
ajouté que l'enseignement il le savait
était un dossier explosif
on l'a appris il ya quelques minutes
paris a décidé de fermer son ambassade à
kaboul c'est une mesure provisoire prise
pour des raisons de sécurité c'est vrai
que l'afghanistan est dans une nouvelle
tourmente les soviétiques se retire et
kaboul a peur il semble en effet que les
soviétiques soit décidé à accélérer le
retrait de l'armée rouge avant même la
mi février
mais tout le monde craint que l'on
assiste après la libération un immense
règlements de compte et déjà donc
beaucoup de diplomates s'apprête à
partir patricia cost kaboul sous la
neige est devenue la ville de toutes les
rumeurs
renvoyé en écho par les montagnes qui
l'encerclent et c'est le sauve-qui-peut
il a suffi que depuis deux jours les
militaires soviétiques accélère le pas
pour quitter la ville et que l'on parle
d'un retrait de l'armée rouge beaucoup
plus précipitée que prévu pour le 5
février dit-on maintenant au lieu du 15
et les ambassades ferment les unes après
les autres
après les allemands de l'ouest ce sont
les américains qui ont plié bagage
entraînement aujourd'hui les japonais
l'italie devrait suivre très rapidement
la grande-bretagne et la france qui
viennent d'annoncer ce soir l'heure des
filion de rapatrier tout leur personnel
pour ne prendre aucun risque
et pourtant l'une des rumeurs de kaboul
et peut-être qu'il ne se passera rien
compter ceux qui restent attendent des
convois de ravitaillement ou la
prochaine bataille de kaboul entre
afghans cette fois en espagne
l'offensive diplomatique des
palestiniens yasser arafat
yasser arafat pardon est en effet à
madrid il a rencontré aujourd'hui trois
ministres des affaires étrangères
européens
le grec l'espagnol et le français depuis
quelque temps en effet l'europe souhaite
avoir une influence concrète sur le
règlement des affaires du proche orient
yasser arafat a aussi rencontré le roi
juan carlos en france les élections
municipales il n'est pas trop tôt pour
en parler je vous rappelle qu elles
auront lieu les 12 et 19 mars prochains
à gauche une trentaine de primaires au
maximum entre ps et pcf c'est ce qu'a
affirmé marcel debarge aujourd'hui
martel de barges c'est lui qui négocie
pour le parti socialiste pour les
municipales à 2 sera mobilisé bien sûr
comme toujours et tous les vendredis
d'ici au mois de mars le portrait d'une
grande ville de province
portrait politique mais aussi portraits
en profondeur à travers toutes les
facettes d'une ville ce soir c'est lyon
que nous avons choisi côté politique
d'abord et bien pas de surprise ce sera
une victoire de la droite
ça c'est sûr mais qui à droite il y à là
bas une véritable primaire véronique
sainte olive
si la division à lyon pèse lourd c'est
qu'il s'agit avant tout d'une affaire de
succession
francisque collomb 78 maire sortant
apparentée udf a du souffle l'occupent
le fauteuil d'edouard herriot depuis 12
ans son bilan leur avis il n'envisage
pas de s'arrêter
on a l'âge de ses artères
les médecins me donnent 65 ans et
les les kinésithérapeutes qui s'occupe
de ma campe de la forme physique le
disent aussi très mois ci un homme qui a
un qui en permanence de tension qui fait
des efforts qui est qui le coût est
celui d'un sportif
alors comment comment comment
voulez-vous que j'abandonne c'est ma vie
michel noir au contraire est persuadé
que le renouvellement est indispensable
un renouvellement qu'il incarnerait
volontiers et qui lui permettrait de
faire tomber la deuxième ville de france
dans l'escarcelle rpr mais lyon on
n'aime pas qu'on la bouscule et michel
noir qui l'a appris à ses dépends aux
dernières municipales joue cette fois
les notables tranquille on a déjà
l'image de michel noir grand-père à 45
ans ont donc je suppose un jeune premier
je suis je suis déjà dans le paysage
lyonnais une image stable
cannes se font virer dans le beaujolais
il a pris de la bouteille
le leader de la gauche se réjouit de la
division même si elle ne fait pas
basculer la ville de son côté du côté de
l'hôtel de ville en revanche on
s'inquiète
les partisans de francisque collomb le
pousse donc à annoncer qu'il passera la
main en cours de mandat rendre --sous
ville brillant avocat première adjoint
tourne depuis assez longtemps
il rêve de se placer mais raymond barre
qui s'apprête à rejoindre l'équipe
francisque collomb élargi le jeu il ya
des gens qui ont un âge qu'ils ont pris
parce qu'ils ont vécu et tu ne sont pas
réduits à l'état de masisi je ne pense
pas que le maire de lyon soit réduit à
l'état de gâtisme et puis c'est son de
raisonner sur un homme providentiel dont
on dit qu'il pourrait providentiel
raisons non sur une équipe les listes
mijote dans le plus grand secret les on
murmure qu'elle à mairieux serait prêt à
rejoindre francisque collomb
cet ami personnel de jacques chirac
leader de la bourgeoisie industrielle
n'a pas accepté la primaire pour michel
noir le coup est rude mais dans une
ville où louis xiv a négligé de chaussée
et prier tout est possible
lyon ce n'est pas seulement une bagarre
politique de collines de fleuves et un
long passé historique lyon c'est aussi
une ville moderne une ville qui réussit
voici un modèle lyonnais de réussite
jean michel aulas en 83 il crée une
petite société d'informatique cinq ans
après il est à la tête d'un groupe de
600 personnes claude rey jean georges
badia reportage jean michel aulas 39 ans
un lyonnais pressé mais pas stressé une
histoire qui se confond avec la réussite
de son entreprise de conseil en
informatique créée en 83 et qui bat
aujourd'hui tous les records de
croissance rentabilité bénéfices
effectif jean michel aulas est un
premier de la classe sans complexe c'est
pas toujours facile effectivement dans
le contexte français
d'assumer cette réussite ceci étant je
crois que elle ne doit rien à personne
c'est à dire que nous avons fait en
sorte de créer et de développer
il ne s'agit pas de transmission ou de
reprises de choses existantes et à
partir de là je suis bien dans ma peau
dans l'entreprise la réussite sa fiche
l'introduction de la société au second
marché de la bourse de lyon a été
déterminante
la bourse a joué le 19 juin 1986 pour
cegid le rôle d'un formidable formidable
accélérateur de la croissance cette
occasion la notoriété de la société a
prodigieusement augmenté elle lui a
permis depuis d'engranger une puissance
financière considérable
le personnel adhère à la réussite de son
pdg sans état d'âme et sans syndicats on
a beaucoup de boulot donc on pense
d'abord à son boulot bon on est c'est
assez concret niveau des résultats on
voit tout de suite ce qui se passe donc
c'est très motivant on n'a pas le temps
de penser à autre chose pour les
prétendants van dyck et la semaine a été
chargée car la cegid a pris le contrôle
d'une société parisienne haut de gamme
puis jean michel aulas a négocié des
accords à toulouse un déplacement avec
le double casquette pour ce pdg
cumulards
mais monsieur le président de
l'olympique lyonnais ne peut pas être
pris pour un autre c'est vrai que
bernard tapie a pris des initiatives
dans le même sens mais il fait beaucoup
plus de choses que moi et d'autres
choses qui me passionnent pas du tout
pensé la politique par exemple par
exemple mais voilà pour lyon vendredi
prochain nous braqueront le projecteur
sur une autre ville ce sera lille un
chiffre qui est une confirmation en
décembre les prix ont progressé de 0,2
pour cent c'est ce qu'indique l'insee au
total chiffres définitifs la hausse aura
été de 3,1 pour cent pour l'ensemble de
l'année
88 d'autres informations de l'actualité
sur mer dans les airs et sur terre on
commence par saint malo saint pierre et
miquelon ce n'est pas un match de
football c'est une bataille navale
laurent bouvier
écluse bloqué affaires maritimes et
sous-préfectures occupé grève de la faim
qui se poursuivra à l'hôtel de ville
malgré l' annonce de rencontre ce soir
au ministère de la mer et demain à
l'hôtel matignon
l'agitation se poursuit à saint malo la
ville est toujours paralysée en réponse
à la décision gouvernementale
d'interdire de pêche au large de saint
pierre et miquelon
le chalutier malouin grande hermine
53 minutes de retard sur l'horaire prévu
mais lancement parfaitement réussie pour
ariane qui l'année dernière a placé sur
orbite le satellite de
télécommunications international
intelsat 5
avec ce nouveau tir la fusée européenne
enregistre son dixième succès consécutif
depuis la reprise des vols
en septembre 1987
françois mitterrand en visite dans
l'oise ce matin à grandvilliers il
inaugure une un hospice qui avait brûlé
il ya quatre ans une occasion pour le
président de promettre une rénovation de
tous les offices de france d'ici la fin
de son septennat
cet après midi promenade dans bouvet en
compagnie du maire socialiste maltais
rennes salem allocutions et poignées de
main mais aucune allusion du président
aux affaires
les exploits de la médecine qui pose
parfois des problèmes
il s'agit cette fois des enfants
prématurés 5000 chaque année sont
sauvées grâce aux progrès considérables
de la réanimation
il s'agit dans ce cas des grands
prématurés ceux qui sont nés avant
trente deux semaines avant il avait très
peu de chances de survie maintenant on
les sauve presque à 100% mais il y a un
problème il faut les accueillir
et on commence à manquer de lee daniels
du loup voici michael il n'est vieux que
de 28 semaines se dire à peine sept mois
il ne pèse que 950 grammes et il est né
voilà deux jours hier michael serait
déjà mort il est incapable d'assurer lui
même les trois fonctions vitales
respiration température besoins
énergétiques
mais aujourd'hui grâce aux progrès
considérables obstétrie et de la
réanimation néonatale
il a des chances de survivre huit
chances sur dix pour les grands
prématurés qui ont entre 27 et 32
semaines
au total les grands prématurés
représente 1% des naissances 20% des
prématurés soit environ 7000 chaque
année en france
le grand problème c'est qu'on manque de
lits hautement spécialisés pour recevoir
et traiter ces urgences car il y à tous
les autres prématurés et les nourrissons
victimes parfois de maladie grave qu'il
faut aussi assurer en réanimation
un exemple le samu pédiatrique de
clamart est en situation critique en
moyenne 60 jours par an nous arrive
parfois de mettre une heure ou parfois
plus jusqu'à 2
même trois heures pour arriver à
convaincre un service d'accepter de
prendre en surnombre un nouveau-né
intubé et ventilé dans l'avenir la
situation va s'aggraver car les grands
prématurés seront de plus en plus
nombreux et les médecins risquent de se
retrouver dans une position éthique
redoutable celle de devoir choisir entre
deux bébés à sauver faute de lits il
faudrait d'abord plus d'infirmières et
de médecins qui font un travail
spécialisé et épuisant il faudrait aussi
encore plus de matériel très sophistiqué
mais qui vieillit très vite il est
évident que on ne tolérera plus qu'un
enfant meurt sans qu'on lui ait donné la
possibilité de survivre avec les
techniques que nous maîtrisons
actuellement si bien que l'on peut
supposer qu'il y aura de plus en plus
d'interventions médicales ch ses enfants
d'autant qu' on va accepter sur le plan
médical d'extraire ces enfants lorsque
une maladie maternelle par exemple va
mettre en jeu le pronostic de la moment
où va empêcher la croissance du foetus
in utero de façon correcte
michael qui est né dans la région
parisienne a sans doute beaucoup plus de
chances de survivre que s'il était né
dans une autre région
il existe en effet une inégalité dans
les équipements des services de
réanimation néonatale selon les régions
or d'autres michael sont comme lui entre
la vie et la mort
ouverture ce matin du salon de la bd à
angoulême il ya nous avons présenté chez
les étrangers qui étaient en vedette à
cette fête de la bande dessinée et bien
ce soir deux français
en effet un jury de professionnels a
sélectionné les dix dessinateurs
français inévitable pour cette année
alors pascal deschamps a choisi deux
deux styles différence des devoirs mais
l'un et l'autre présente l'avant garde
et l'avenir de la bd
il fallait s'y attendre quand un
indispensable rencontre un autre
indispensable
il se met à dessiner indispensable donc
le corrosif star d'un jour de didier
tronchet ou l'attrait esthétique filles
du modèle de jean-claude gauting ne vous
fiez pas à son air studieux tronchet est
un provocateur personne n'échappe à son
trait ravageur parfois grossiers qu'ils
luttaient pas de bien dessiné mon but
c'est de raconter des histoires avec le
peu de moyens graphiques que j'ai et je
trouve que j'ai plus de mérite à faire
de la bd sans savoir dessiner je trouve
très méchant avec les gens dans vos dons
vous bande dessinée qu'est ce qui vous
en fait je trouve intéressant d'être sur
la frange entre rire et là où on sait
pas trop s'il faut en rire aussi font
pleurer et j'aime bien créer un malaise
si jean-claude getting est plutôt du
genre effacer ses dessins à l'encré de
chine ont fini par s'imposer ça n'a pas
été facile
le noir et blanc n'a plus la cote
getting est avant tout un graphiste qui
fait des bd pour raconter des histoires
tristes se tient aussi au dessin qui qui
qui est orienté dans ce sens là les cinq
bris donc
priori plutôt des histoires tristes un
garçon triste us juste très triste alors
tronchet gauting getting tronchet à vous
de choisir
à moins qu'il vous soit déjà devenus
tous les deux indispensables
voilà olivier de kersauson a perdu son
premier pari il s'agit de voile bien sûr
il ne fera pas le tour du monde sans
escale il a dû relâcher au cap en
afrique du sud pour faire réparer ses
pilotes automatiques en revanche
kersauson est toujours en course pour
battre le record du monde
le record pardon du tour du monde en
solitaire il faudrait ce brisé pour de
kersauson l'autre monde son trimaran la
lâcher ou plus exactement deux de ses
trois pilotes électrique on connaît les
avaries il devenait alors impossible de
continuer de kersauson déçu lui qui
voulait battre le record du tour du
monde sans escale est obligé de
s'arrêter aux quatre ans à quelle
vitesse tu vas mettre combien de temps
pour jusqu'au cap
sais tu pensé combien de temps le banc
des regrets car depuis son départ de
brest le 28 décembre tout s'était plutôt
bien passé mais désormais de cars se
sont fait route arrière pour réparer
ensuite ils comptent repartir mais le
record de philippe monnet tient toujours
la boucle en 129 jours et 17 heures
la mode fans partie c'était cette
semaine la grande semaine des
collections de printemps à paris nous
vous en avons parlé dans nos dernières
éditions
couturier toutes griffes dehors et
journée hystérique bien sûr pour les
mannequins alors c'est pourquoi à notre
tableau d'honneur ce soir un mannequin
dalmat bonsoir dalmat je précise que
vous êtes d'origine brésilienne j'espère
qu'on va vous voir ça y est on vous voit
bonsoir dalmat alors vous êtes mannequin
vedette vous êtes reconnu fait dans le
monde entier
vous avez même l'année dernière remporté
un prix très très convoité à new york
l'année dernière alors simplement je
voudrais vous demander combien de
collection vous avez présenté cette
semaine
cette semaine j'ai présenté à peu près 7
cette collection est oui cette
collection ça veut dire bon cette
collection pour la semaine mais ça veut
dire chaque jour par exemple combien de
fois vous êtes habillé déshabiller en
est là ce vraiment énormément peut-être
taxant fois 300 fois ces normes afin de
compenser le manceau part et je contrôle
paraît un peu partout mais ça parce que
vous êtes un mannequin très convoité un
mannequin vedette ça veut dire que vous
vivez ou d'abord je vous non pas votre
adresse personnelle je vous demande la
ville où il vivait mais vous n'êtes
jamais à new york j'ai tout le temps
partout
oui presque les villes du monde r oui et
normalement je voyage beaucoup parce que
bon voilà c'est ça mon métier je voyage
et surtout ici alors alors dalmat vous
savez que être mannequin c'est un métier
très très convoité par tous les jeunes à
peu près aussi convoité que présentateur
de télévision alors simplement est-ce
que ça fait maintenant un certain nombre
d'années que vous le pratiquer ce métier
est ce que avec le recul vous trouvez
que c'est un métier formidable
ah oui bien sûr parce que je trouve
qu'ils
ça nous apporte beaucoup on peut faire
tellement que voyager on peut connaître
de jean différentes
alors c'est vraiment excitant c'est
aussi très occupé on est toujours un
courant ont couru on attend alors c'est
quelque chose qui bon c'est ça prend
beaucoup mais c'est super on voyage on
est jeune et belle et on gagne de
l'argent avec pas mal
samad oui à combien combien bah écoute
assez pour vivre bien vous voyagez pour
faire l'analyse
qu'est ce qu'on fait après parce que
bien sûr c'est un métier enfin je veux
dire c'est comme les footballeurs
professionnels enfin c'est pas tout à
fait pareil mais ça veut dire que c'est
un métier qu'on ne pratique que quelques
années qu'est ce qu'on fait après
mais après je ne sais pas s'il est
tellement des options il a déjà offert
le cinéma il ya des autres qu'il faut
quelque chose dans la mort il ya des
actionnaires
c'est le côté fermé je sais pas si tu es
vous coupez votre non vraiment j'ai
aucune idée mais peut-être s'est passé
quelques années des et vient le message
et profits
merci beaucoup d'allemands voit la fin
de cette édition du journal des
pronostics pour le tiercé de demain
peut-être je ne sais pas je n'en suis
pas sûr non j'en suis pas sûr du tout
même
alors tout de suite c'est la météo avec
josée béland lapierre dont quelques
secondes si voilà les pronostics
formidable ses sauts de pierrette brès
je m'en doutais 3,6 has à 7 4 9 5 13
j'espère que vous avez eu le temps de
noter je vous disais donc aussitôt après
la pub josé devant la pierre pour des
prévisions météo la dernière édition du
journal ce sera vers 23h avec henri
saint denis après apostrophes et puis ce
week-end comme d'habitude vous
retrouverez daniel bilalian betty dureau
philippe gassot à lundi de 20 heures
excellent week end
vous venez